class dojo is a platform that helps
teachers and parents build character
strengths with kids teachers use the
class dojo and mobile app to give kids
positive feedback in the classroom for
all the things they're doing well and
then they collect all this data which
they share with parents at home we
probably spoke to Sam actually spoke to
about 200 teachers on the phone well
they kept telling us was that they had
this big problem that they were facing
regarding behavior the more we talk to
them the more we became convinced in
this whistling example it's crazy to
think that three years ago Koster didn't
exist and now I think there's close to
two million teachers who use us in front
of around 40 million kids every day in
28 languages and 148 countries like the
list goes on if teachers like something
it'll spread that quickly teachers want
to be able to walk around the classroom
and perform without being tied to a
computer and so we start looking at
building a native app for Google Play
and with the launch of Google Play for
education that was a natural fit for us
to dive an so we want to reach as many
teachers as possible what we found was
do Google Play for education was a great
way to do that because we have all this
visibility on the store we like the fact
that we can push instant updates because
that allows us to respond to user
demands very quickly I think one of my
top pieces of advice for other
developers in the Google Play for
education school is they really think
about the seasonality of Education
you'll see much better results if you
launch something in the fall when
teachers are actually making adoption
decisions localizing the app makes a lot
of sense here in the United States
there's a lot of people who are changing
the Apple anguish because their native
tongue is not English it's really
important for them to have a simple
experience that they can use very easily
it's important for them to be able to
install your app easily and sign into it
very easily and that's where I think
Google Play for education has been
really helpful I think one of Klosters
proudest moments was about two months
ago when we passed this amazing
milestone for the company which was a
billion pieces of positive feedback
given by teachers to students that was
pretty excited